okay a sitting florida representative
randy fine who represents the 53rd
district in florida threatened joe biden
with gun violence in the aftermath of
the uvalde texas shooting you have a
shooting okay
and then joe biden wants to do something
about gun violence
and an elected official
threatens biden with guns
he tweeted quote
i have news for the embarrassment that
claims to be our president
try to take our guns and you'll learn
why the second amendment was written in
the first place that's an elected
official ladies and gentlemen he should
be immediately removed from office the
secret service should visit him and have
a nice chat
and he was confronted about what he
tweeted
and he kind of doubles down weirdly now
as a warning to people watching randy
fine is extremely red in this video just
as a heads up listen to this guy what a
doofus
who have mental problems i think when
the president of the united states gets
on the day of the mass shooting and says
he's going to come and take people's
guns away that's incendiary
he turned his speech into a speech on
gun control it was hugely inappropriate
it was hugely inappropriate to do that
day if they are going to start this they
cannot expect us to sit silently while
they try to strip our second amendment
you know it doesn't really help your
cause when joe biden says hey i don't
know
we still haven't really tried any gun
safety regulations maybe we should for
you to threaten to shoot the president
implicitly it doesn't really help your
cause that we should be just doing
nothing about the gun element
incredible
all right he's got to go uh and of
course as usual they insist oh it's
he's injecting politics he's injecting
politics these are decisions made by
political figures
how on earth
do you address something that
politicians should deal with
without injecting politics and of course
it's used as a pejorative well you're
injecting politics oh yeah well it's a
political issue why is that bad
that should just be the i mean that
should just be the reaction
yeah this is a political issue
the people are coming to us as
politicians saying please do something
so who should they go to are they going
to go to i don't know doctors
to pass some law about guns uh it's an
absurd situation and even more absurd is
that this guy is trying to say it would
be really bad to take anyone's guns even
though that's not what joe biden said
it would be really bad to take people's
guns and to prove to you how bad of an
idea it would be
i'm going to threaten to use my gun on
the president
you're making the case that your guns
should be taken sir what a vile and
disgusting guy
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price little spoon makes
everything fresh just like homemade but
it's delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop it in the fridge or freezer
and it is ready when you are they have
100 organic cold pressed baby food for
every eating stage awesome food for
toddlers and for kids they even just
launched a new line of on-the-go
smoothies that kids love everything is
nutritionally balanced no junk food but
it is kid approved it's food that
they'll actually eat and enjoy and you
can't beat the prices with kids meals
under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience 50
off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code pacman
the link is down below